[Music]
some of our competitors haven't they've
tilted the Tilted the field a little bit
so I think President Trump is just
trying to level it back out frankly we
don't we don't win by assessing tariffs
that basically come back to bite us so
I'm disappointed if you put a 10% tariff
on aluminum how much do you think that
increases the price of a six-pack of
beer you have any idea a cent one cent
I'm gonna tell you a penny how much you
think it increases the price of an
automobile if all the costs are passed
through $45 if you look at the problems
here that they're saying big price
effects negligible price effects so this
is leftist economic policy and we've
tried it a whole bunch of times in the
last two centuries and every time
American families have suffered well
it's been quite a back-and-forth over
the last day and a half since the
president said he is going to institute
tariffs on steel and aluminum not a lot
of talk about it today obviously from
the president but a lot of tweets this
morning when a country USA is losing
many billions of dollars on trade with
virtually every country it does business
with trade wars are good and easy to win
example when we are down a hundred
billion dollars with a certain country
and they get cute don't trade anymore we
win big it's easy we must protect our
country and our workers our steel
industry is in bad shape if you don't
have steel you don't have a country
when a country taxes our products coming
in at say 50% and we tax the same
product coming into our country at zero
not fair or smart we will soon be
starting reciprocal taxes so that we
will charge the same thing as they
charge us 800 billion dollar trade
deficit have no choice exclamation point
we start there with our panel let's
bring in Steve Hayes editor-in-chief of
the Weekly Standard Lesley Marshall
syndicated talk show radio host and Fox
News media analyst Howard Kurtz okay
Steve you know obviously a lot of
pushback from allies who feel this is
the wrong thing a lot of pushback from
Capitol Hill there are some allies of
the presidents both on the Republican
side a Democratic side who say they've
been waiting for this well I think a lot
of us have been waiting for this in the
sense that the president made obby
during the campaign that this is what he
wanted to do so nobody should be
particularly surprised by his actions I
think what's surprising is the
president's language you don't typically
hear a president are you for raising
tariffs by announcing that he's starting
a trade war and then trying to spin his
trade war as a good thing for the
country and I think if you read what the
president tweeted this morning there's
no light way to put this he doesn't
understand how trade works and he's
talking about it as if it's an 800
billion dollar loss on a ledger
that's not how trade works we've got a
long history of this go back to Adam
Smith you go back before I think the
other problem is the White House doesn't
really know what its own arguments are
on trade you just saw you just played
Peter evarro saying that this was only a
$45 per car tax if you look at the
numbers that Wilbur Ross gave and it's
in a different interview to talk about
175 vehicles $1.00 per car tax that's a
big difference the the total if you use
the Wilbur Ross numbers you're talking
about 17 million vehicles sold then
Scott Lincecum from the Cato Institute
that's estimates that that's about a
three billion dollar tax new tax these
are taxes these taxes will be passed on
to the American consumer it will protect
the steel industry and it will hurt
consumers more broadly right here is the
Commerce Secretary on the bout on CNBC
at today Wilbur Ross you've got to look
at the job creation and the impact on
American employees American employees
have borne the brunt of all the imported
steel and aluminum that's been coming in
so corporate America may complain the
president is taking up the banner of Mr
and Mrs America huh well he's right I
mean when I agree with the president you
know and some Republicans you know you
you have to say there's something going
on here that actually may be right when
we look at what's happened to the United
States with manufacturing and with steel
what Wilbur Ross says is right on and
when you have American steel being used
and being purchased and GM uses
percent American steel but the United
States imports more steel than any other
country that is problematic we do have a
trade deficit that has to be addressed
if you have these terrorists in place
you were then putting middle-class
workers the very people who put the
president in his position in the Oval
Office in states like Wisconsin in
Pennsylvania
throughout the Rust Belt you're putting
these people back to work and you know
another thing when we talk about
infrastructure people that I've spoken
to say they're the steel that is made in
China where we get a lot of our steel
from is not the quality of the steel
made here in the United States and I
don't know about you have you ever
bought those t-shirts three for ten
bucks they fall apart in the wash after
one wash I don't want to drive home for
bridges like that I don't want to be in
buildings like that so I think if we're
gonna really put America first as the
president says this is actually a good
step you think you'll get many Democrats
to so I do think so I do think so far
let me put up the support domestic steel
demand by sector this is according to
the American Iron and Steel Institute
and you look at the percentages
construction automotive machinery energy
it essentially touches all aspects of
American life domestic aluminum
consumption there you see transportation
packaging construction electrical
machinery obviously the beer companies
and the the companies that use aluminum
also raising problems here yeah like old
tariffs it hurts many industries that
helps a couple of industries look Donald
Trump has been talking about other
countries taking America to the cleaners
since the 1980s but as president he's
been somewhat restrained in acting on
this by people like Gary Cohen the chief
economic adviser but now the staff kind
of thinning out he's doing what he wants
unfortunately for him it's over the
objections we heard Ben Sasse they're on
tape of many Republicans who have always
run as free traders it's a position
that's mostly just approved it
that obviously more approved of by
Democrats so it's an another example of
Donald Trump being more of an
independent president who sometimes
takes a middle ground position at the
same time we have to recognize that
you know you can hold up a luminance a
it's only one cent but the we're already
hearing lots of rumblings of retaliation
from other countries trade wars may be
good in president's view they may be fun
but they can be complicated and they can
hurt America on that other issue Chris
Cox with the NRA tweeting I had a great
meeting tonight that was last night with
Donald Trump and the vice president
president and vice president we all want
Safe Schools mental health reform and to
keep guns away from dangerous people
POTUS and V POTUS support the Second
Amendment support strong due process and
don't want gun control NRA Magga make
America great again walking back against
again that due process comment in that
cabinet open hearing what does this says
I mean is is there something that will
move forward do you think Steve who
knows honestly I have no idea we try to
project this we try to predict this talk
to people in the White House they try to
predict what the president is gonna say
at any given time he wasn't supposed to
say or he wasn't planning on saying what
he said yesterday to the pool cameras
about trade this was totally ad-lib as
how he points out this is something he's
believed for a long time so it's not
accurate for people to say this comes
out yeah but he wasn't he wasn't
planning on saying that he certainly
wasn't planning on saying what he said
about gun control in the meeting the
bipartisan meeting the other day he
wasn't planning his advisors weren't
planning on him embracing democratic
talking points on immigration just a
couple of weeks ago he's he's repeatedly
said over the past several weeks things
that have pleased Democrats now whether
he follows through on them whether he
acts on them he sounded in comments on
guns immigration and trade a lot more
like a Liberal Democrat than he has a
conservative Republican it is like the
gun debate in that this president
doesn't follow the Republican Orthodox
playbook but the fact that the NRA is
coming out and providing cover now on
that side I mean he's got all kinds of
different things that talking points
that are happen and that's part of the
problem is sort of like you know what
day is that and what do you believe and
what will he go forward with and if we
look at history Congress
has not been able to get this done when
the Republicans are in control and
certainly even when Democrats were in
control we shall see